in einer Großstadt wie meine Heimatstadt
Köln gibt es immer etwas zu entdecken
und das betrifft zum Glück auch die
restaurant-landschaft es gibt immer
wieder neue Entdeckungen immer wieder
neue Läden die man ausprobieren kann und
leider natürlich auch den ein oder
anderen Laden der schließt heute
konzentrieren wir uns aber auf die
schönen Dinge wir testen drei
verschiedene neue Eröffnungen ich freue
mich sehr darauf es gibt wirklich immer
wieder Überraschung welche heute dabei
sind seht ihr im Video viel Spaß damit
wir gehen zum ersten squad
und wir kommen zum ersten Spot Kaffee
caprista der Hype ums Frühstück wenig
abbrechen zumindest hier in Köln ich
habe ganz viel von diesem Laden gehört
und was macht ihm besonders ist er
wirklich so gut das testen wir heute
schauen wir uns das an es ist ein
frühstückskonzept wo es wirklich nur
Frühstück und Brunch gibt italienische
Einfluss scheinbar der Laden befindet
sich auf der Venloer Straße also im
Herzen von Ehrenfeld nicht weit vom
kebapland was er bestimmt kennt und der
Innenraum überzeugt schon mal durch
seine Detail Verliebtheit also wir haben
ganz klar so süditalienische
Designsprache wir haben Zitronen wir
haben Fliesen wir haben helle Farben all
das sieht sehr gemütlich aus aber gucken
wir mal was wir bestellen wir haben uns
die Karte angeschaut es gibt
verschiedene Frühstücksklassiker also
expenedig Drama Max und so weiter und so
fort aber wollte sich mit italienischen
Einfluss bzw auch so ein bisschen mit
Ehrenfeld Einfluss also es gibt Sucuk
natürlich und so erstens eine bunte
Mischung ich glaube da kommt jeder auf
seine Kosten das schon mal cool was
natürlich auch auffällt ist die etwas
höheren Preise also kann man auch nicht
anders sagen gut der Laden ist Fans
wieder laden ist neu war bestimmt teuer
einzurichten deshalb hat das auch seinen
Daseinsberechtigung aber ich habe zum
Beispiel neuen Eck Benedict tappen
vorgestellt mit Truppe weil ich dachte
mir muss es bestellen 17,90 € schauen
wir mal was sonst noch so kommt bin sehr
gespannt ich habe viel von dem Laden
gehört gucken wir was auf uns zukommt
[Musik]
danke schön
die ganze Pracht ist jetzt angekommen
wir haben einmal krüffeleck Benedikt wir
haben eine Frittata wir haben ein
Pistazien Croissant und Dave ist auch
mit dabei hat Sucuk AC Benedikt ich
glaube auf sizilianischen Land Brot auf
sieht sie gar nicht schon dran also man
sieht auf jeden Fall die Optik der
Teller spielt hier eine große Rolle
alles ist sehr schön gestylt so wie der
Laden auch es ist natürlich nur sekundär
beim Essen weil es muss vor allem gut
schmecken und 17,90 €, das ist jetzt
keine riesen Portion was ich vor mir
stehen habe deshalb muss es wirklich gut
schmecken probieren wir das ganze mal
ich glaube die sind Füchse weil ich
glaube das hier ist frischer Trüffel und
das hier ist so eingelegter aus dem Glas
der natürlich preislich im erhebliche
Unterschied hat dann haben wir unten so
ein trüffelpartie welches aber häufig
auch so eine richtige Intensität also
quasi Pilze vielleicht auch andere
pizzastrophe mit Trüffelöl das möchte
ich gar nicht überbewerben wenn ich will
vor allem wissen wie es schmeckt oh ja
das Land wurde es auch wirklich
respektlos
sieht schon gut aus alter wirklich gut
aus ich finde es ziemlich wenn es zu
flüssig ist auch nicht so geil wenn das
so komplett auf den Teller läuft dann ja
auch sehr sehr gespannt auf dein
Feedback boah ich bin auch super
gespannt ne probieren wir
Trüffel mit Sauce Hollandaise
funktioniert sehr gut aber ich bin noch
nie vorgestellt funktioniert wirklich
sehr gut dieser viel Zeit und
trüffelprodukten kriegt man auf jeden
Fall eine kräftigen Truppe Geschmack
raus was ja das Wichtigste halt mal wenn
jetzt einfach nur frischen drücke drüber
gehobelt hätten dann schmeckt das ja gar
nicht so krass Geschmack bin ich super
für dieses leicht lauwarme ein Top die
Hollandaise überdeckt auch gar nicht so
den [ __ ] Geschmack also diese fettige
oder an der sieht das Trüffelöl und so
schon sehr lecker als nächstes Frittata
wir haben ja einen ganz klaren Italien
Bezug beim Kaffeekapsel Star cabrik und
Frittata das italienische Omelette mit
Parmesan und so weiter und so fort muss
natürlich auch gut sein
zur Safran oben drauf ich habe es ein
Paprika färben so wie man es erwartet
Eric hält das besser als ich aber das
ist so ein bisschen so TUI Pater halt
genau also das ist schon eher
durchgebacken ja genau schmeckt lecker
und ich weiß nur einmal ins Croissant
weil das muss auch gut sein das ist
eigentlich interessant weil das ist ja
ein reines Frühstückslokal und in
Italien ist ja frühstückskultur sehr
moderat im Vergleich zur allgemeinen
Esskultur bei der frühstückst du halt
morgens wenn schon so ein Cornetto
deshalb muss das hier auf der Karte sein
und es muss auch gut sein und vor allem
so ein schönes angesichts des Cornett
habe ich noch nie gesehen habe ich auch
noch nicht gesehen ich mache mir die
Hände dreckig nehmen das ganze Ding
einfach hoch mit Pistazien kriegen
befüllt auch oft
auf jeden Fall ein sehr charmanter Abend
das Essen ist lecker wenn man Finales
Fazit seht ihr wenn wir aufgegessen
haben die Sonne küsst uns wir sind
fertig haben uns das Croissant noch
einpacken lassen weil es einfach zu viel
war wir haben jetzt das sind die zwei
Hauptpunkte 83 Euro für drei Leute
Frühstück bezahlt schon teuer jeder
Kaffee Flasche Wasser und das ist der
Punkt es ist schon teuer aber wenn man
gemütlich sitzen will an so einem
Sonntag brunchen so ein bisschen Zeit
mit Freunden verbringen will dann ist
das ein schöner Ort um das zu tun
vielleicht nicht so für Casual mal
schnell schnell frühstücken gehen aber
wenn man einfach Bock auf das Ambiente
hat dann ist das ein superladen ich bin
gespannt auf den nächsten
[Musik]
wir stehen vor dem nächsten Laden und
wir unschwer erkennen könnt ist es der
Italiener zumindest möchte es der
Italiener sein es gibt natürlich viele
gute italienische Restaurants in Köln
umso spannender ist es wie sich dieses
neue Restaurant schlagen wird es gibt
dort Pizza es gibt Pasta ich sage euch
so viel ich habe da so ein Gefühl dass
es auf jeden Fall ein guter Laden ist
wir sind hier auf der Aachener Straße
also der foodmeile eigentlich in Köln
das ist ein hart umkämpftes Pflaster
deshalb muss hier wirklich einiges
geboten werden wenn wir reingehen sehen
wir schon an Design oder auf jeden Fall
nicht gespart wir haben wirklich viele
schöne interessante Designansätze diese
Leuchtschilder fallen natürlich total
auf und das ist irgendwie schon echt ein
gelungener laden würde ich sagen das hat
man auch wenn man auf der Aachener
Straße ist aber wir gehen rein setzen
uns in die gemütliche Stube und stellen
uns was leckeres zu essen
[Musik]
hier ist die Leute das wollte ich euch
zeigen ich war nämlich um ehrlich zu
sein schon mal hier essen bei dem Laden
und guckt euch bitte diese Pizza an ich
fahre eigentlich jeden Tag wenn ich ins
Büro fahre hier vorbei und habe mich die
ganze Zeit gefragt was hier reinkommt
was das für ein Laden wird und Mamma Mia
ich meine das hier ne habe ich so glaube
ich noch nicht gesehen in Köln so diese
wunderschönen kleinen Bläschen so manch
einer würde denken dass das hier
verbrannt ist aber das ist was für mich
wirklich so eine next level Pizza
ausmacht so dieser getigerte Rand auch
der Boden von der Pizza schöner
Farbverlauf das ist wirklich geil also
ich freue mich sehr dass man das jetzt
essen kann die Pizza hier ist jetzt eine
lucha Pizza süditalienische scharfe
Peperoni Wurst die nicht so geschnitten
sondern quasi so quetscht wird weil die
relativ weich ist ich mag ja gerne
scharfes essen also noch frische Chilis
dabei natürlich Falten muss man und wir
probieren
es kommt nicht von ungefähr dass diese
Pizza so gut ist nun zu der hier
Pizzabäcker ist hat gelernt bei
Francesco erlazzo und wenn ihr meinen
Kanal verfolgt dann wisst ihr es
vielleicht was ist der amtierende
Weltmeister im Pizza backen und wir
waren mal bei ihm haben in Ingelheim die
Pizza probiert dann chesco erlasso er
ist nicht nur hier sondern auch hier ich
muss mich gerade schon bedanken ich
wollte ihm die Hand geben einfach für
diese Pizza weil ich habe das noch nicht
gegessen so und ich sage euch ehrlich
vieles davon erinnert mich daran weil
wir haben diesen fluffigen aber
knusprigen Rand hört euch das an Sonne
zu den drückst du runter und der kommt
wieder hoch du hast trotzdem in der
Mitte so der Boden hat immer noch so
eine gewisse Stabilität so dass du nicht
einfach so Teig kaufst gefühlt sondern
der hat immer noch bist die Pizza in
Ingelheim hat was mit mir gemacht und
diese Pizza macht auch etwas mit mir für
meinen Gaumen ist das hier eine richtig
richtig gute Kreation alleine für die
Pizza lohnt sich hier vorbeizuschauen
ich finde wirklich gute Pizza erkennt
man daran dass man sich auf den Rand
freut so dass man nicht den Rand liegen
lässt sondern dass man sich boah jetzt
habe ich noch Rand und das ist hier
wirklich so also ich freue mich die zu
verdrücken schauen uns einfach mal an
was hier sonst noch so zu bieten gibt
wir werfen ganz schnell noch einen Blick
auf die Karte also wie gesagt Pizza
gibt's hier sehr gut Vorspeisen haben
wir ich mag es auch gerne wenn die Karte
so digital ist deshalb muss ich euch
auch noch zeigen also wirklich viele
viele Pizza Variationen oder so eine
kleine Hasen Pizza für Kinder dann passt
da gibt's natürlich auch wie beim
richtigen Italiener Salate Fisch und
Fleisch und Desserts also für so einen
relativ kleinen Laden eigentlich echt
eine große Auswahl nicht so teuer es
gibt schon so eine kleine Preisspanne
also es gibt immer so eine Premium
Variante aber auch so ein baseline
Modell also man kann schon ein bisschen
Geld ausgeben wie eine Pizza kostet
18,90 €, aber es hat mit pistaziencreme
und so aber es gibt auch einen für 10 €
ist auf jeden Fall eine neue Öffnung die
man auf dem Schirm haben sollte und die
Pizza könnte für mich meine
Lieblingspizza in Köln sein meine neue
Lieblingspizza die Pizza war wirklich
sehr sehr gut wir machen gerade einen
kleinen Verdauungsspaziergang und dann
geht es schon zum letzten Laden für den
heutigen Tag und zwar zum Laden von
einer Kollegin Influenza Kollegin die
ich persönlich gar nicht kenne wir
gucken uns das Ganze gleich mal an es
ist ein Croissant ich
[Musik]
hinter uns seht ihr Madame Croissant und
wir haben uns einige Croissants
einpacken lassen vier Stück an der Zeit
weil es gibt hier nur Take Away man kann
hier gar nicht sitzen deshalb setzen wir
uns ins gemütliche Studio ins Büro und
lassen uns die Croissants hoffentlich
schmecken los geht's angekommen in der
Küche können wir jetzt die Croissants
von Madame Croissant testen und falls
ihr neugierig seid welche Kollegin
dahinter steckt die jana carloe hat
diesen Laden mit eröffnet also sie ist
eine von drei Partnern wir haben uns
gerade das ganze noch mal erklären
lassen und ja ihr habt es wahrscheinlich
gerade schon bei den Aufnahmen aus dem
Laden gesehen die Croissants machen
einiges her wir haben ja einmal Pistazie
Zitronencreme Snickers und Lotus
Cheesecake allesamt sehr interessante
Kreationen und es erinnert mich an eine
Sache Royal Donuts also sage ich wie es
ist aber aber es gibt einen kleinen aber
feinen Unterschied ich bin kein riesen
Fan von dem Royal Donuts Prinzip dass
man quasi auf dem Donut so übelst viel
Süßkram draufhaut und ihn noch krasser
macht so gleiches gilt für die
Zimtschnecken mit denen das ja schon
passiert ist da gibt es auch so einen
gewissen Hype darum was ich hier aber
gut finde bei Croissants hat das
Tradition ihr habt heute morgen gesehen
Kurzform mit pistaziencreme ist ein
uritalienisches Ding Croissant mit
Cremes in ur-italienisches Ding
gleichzeitig gibt es zwei Madame
Croissant auch herzhafte Croissants also
zum Beispiel mit Apfel Ziegenkäse auch
das ist ein französisches Ding also es
ist irgendwie so ein Kompromiss aus
moderne und Klassik deshalb bin ich sehr
gespannt erik hat sich Snickers
ausgesucht hätte ich mir nicht so
ausgewählt Zitronencreme finde ich aber
sehr interessant weil so Zitrone
Blaubeere immer lecker ich glaube ganz
wirst du das auch heute nicht mehr
helfen können wir brauchen Hilfe ich
pfeife aus dem letzten noch aber ich
habe eine zu Hause die freut sich
bestimmt wenn ich etwas davon mitbringen
die Jungs im Büro freuen sich auch aber
erstmal freue ich mich auf so einen
süßen Bissen zum Abschluss des Tages
muss man sagen muss die Croissants
werden im Haus auch in der eigenen
Backstube selbst gebacken ich lebe
wirklich für so Zitronencreme so Lemon
Curd und so ist mit das geilste finde
ich so das und abwechselnd zum Espresso
oder Cappuccino trinken sehr lecker
müssen noch den Preis im Kopf behalten
wir haben uns freundlicherweise
eingeladen aber man zahlt so um die 5 €
pro Person und das ist schon viel Geld
finde ich so für einen Croissant ich
meine weil wenn man das Vergleich mit
dem Croissant beim Bäcker ist das
natürlich ein ordentlicher
Preisaufschlag klar hier ist noch
einiges mit dabei aber trotzdem ist es
nicht wenig Geld und das Croissant an
sich man wir sind halt auch oh ja wobei
vielleicht muss ich hier mal den
Mittelteil probieren weil hier vorne ist
es relativ weit aber hier hat man gerade
schon gehört dass es auch sehr knusprig
sein kann
die Kollegen meinten auch dass wir zur
Abendstunde natürlich nicht zur
klassischen croissantszeit kommen ne
haben sie auch recht der Rohstoff
Croissant ne der ist lecker aber es ist
nicht das krasseste Croissant aller
Zeiten aber das gepimpte ne das ist so
sehr geschmackvoll also ich mag wirklich
diese Kreation einfach sehr gerne weil
das ist nicht Maxi King Kinder bueno
sonst was draufgehauen sondern das ist
so sehr sehr schön gedacht einfach
hier ist jetzt sogar noch mal so und ich
glaube blaubeermarmelade zum Vorschein
gekommen unten und da muss ich wirklich
sagen das finde ich richtig gut also ich
finde der Laden war super hübsch Hand
gebacken Croissants Pluspunkt nice
Kreation also auch hier eigentlich ist
das so ein bisschen durch die Bank heute
so vielleicht ist das auch einfach der
wirtschaftlichen Lage geschuldet weil
wir müssen sehr nichts vormachen so
gerade muss jeder gucken wo er bleibt
alles ein bisschen teurer aber alle
Läden die wir gefunden haben waren auch
wirklich gut ich mochte alle Läden sehr
gerne kann man bei jedem Laden
vorstellen noch mal hinzugehen ihr könnt
ja mal in die Kommentare schreiben was
euer Lieblingssport war hier ist noch
ein für dich vorgeschlagenes Video und
unten drunter kannst du gerne meinen
Kanal abonnieren würde mir extrem viel
bedeuten vielleicht würde ich sogar mit
Träne vergießen vor Freude deshalb tun
wir den Gefallen wir sehen uns beim
nächsten Mal wieder bis dahin und ciao